[Music]
we play some blind chess craft neural
networks are used in google maps to
predict traffic and ai makes for
thoughtful gifts welcome to ml news it's
monday
hello and welcome friends of the monday
welcome to ml news now to be honest with
you not a lot of stuff happened this
week i guess it's what they call a slow
news day or something like this so i
thought we'd just take a look at more
lightweight things that i came across so
the first one is reconnaissance blind
chess which is a chess variant that is
now also a nurip's 2021 competition the
rules are the same as in regular chess
except you can't see what your opponent
does so every move that you have is
actually split in two you can first use
sort of a oracle to sense the board or a
piece of the board and then after that
you can make your move so now you have
to be strategic about where you use this
sensing and when you make your moves you
have to be strategic because you can
count on making your regular chess moves
but you can also make moves that you
think your opponent won't scout which
makes for some nice surprise attacks the
notion of check is removed and the game
ends when a king is captured so on the
website you can actually play ranked
matchmaking or play a bot so here i'm
the white pieces and it's my turn first
of all to sense now at the beginning it
doesn't make much sense but you can see
you can sense a three by three square
anywhere you want so let's sense here
wow what a surprise uh they're still in
the initial configuration and then make
a move and now the opponent senses you
won't see where they sense and you won't
see their move now i'm not particularly
good at chess but i'm just gonna scout
about here
and you can see that it reveals their
move that they made now had i scouted
somewhere else i would not have seen
that move so now i can react with a bit
of an attack and not only do you have to
pay attention to what your opponent does
but you sort of have to model what your
opponent might know about you and maybe
even from the moves that your opponent
makes you can sort of parse out what
they might or might not know about you
and your pieces so here my opponent goes
for a bit of an attack and i just like
horses horses are nice alright so move
has been made now you do get informed
when a piece of yours is captured or
when you capture a piece so none of that
happened yet so let's sense around here
and that did not reveal anything oh yes
you can pass as well in this game which
makes it even more complicated so i'm
gonna guess uh the opponent guarded this
pawn back there i'm gonna try some
attack here so now it's my turn to sense
i'm gonna sense about here to see if
they countered any of my things so now
is an interesting situation right i have
no indication that anything is in the
way between me and the king now if my
opponent had sensed that i move my
bishop there they would have probably
moved the king out of the way by now so
the king might be here in front yet if
they hadn't scouted it they have no
motivation to move the king at all
therefore i could now just capture the
king i won
i won
great this chess pro magnus carlsen
bring it on bring it on all right this
is reconnaissance blind chess if you're
interested i'll link it in the
description let's see if you can win too
i played against an opponent level of
trout here just for reference there are
various settings and they instruct you
how to build a bot give it a try
next news there's some discussion on
reddit about collab pro now we've
reported previously that collab now has
a new tier called collap pro plus which
gives you even more priority access than
co-lab pro to gpus so now people are
starting to notice that cola pro
subscriptions don't always give them
very good gpus anymore now the thread is
filled with various comments and and the
general opinions of the different people
are that yes probably now that people
have even more priority access if you
are just a pro user you might get less
access b
collab is still one of the most cost
efficient ways of running on a gpu on
the planet and see a lot of people still
do get good gpus with colab pro so it
could just have been a problem of some
kind of usage spike so make of that as
you will for what it's worth google
never promised to give you good gpus
they simply promise to give you priority
access and that's about that it's just
important to be aware if you're
considering collab pro if you really
rely on getting good gpus all the time
then the collab pro plus might be for
you
in a big collaboration between deepmind
waymo google amazon facebook ai and cai
lab researchers have used graph neural
networks to do better traffic prediction
specifically they talk about eta
prediction estimated time of arrival and
that in real time so the way they do it
is they segment roads or paths in
general into these segments and then
they use graph neural networks to
integrate all live information to give
you an accurate estimate of when you'll
arrive the interesting thing is they
don't do that much crazy stuff with this
graph neural networks they have some
tricks up their sleeves like the use of
meta gradients in order to control hyper
parameters but in general it just sounds
like a really solid engineering effort
and this is deployed in google maps
these statistics here show you by how
much the eta prediction accuracies have
improved and sometimes this is really
staggering so you see great improvements
across the board sometimes up to 50
percent i'm not exactly sure what the
metric here is but 50 is a big number
can we all agree yeah good job
okay let's look at some helpful
libraries and data sets the first is
isac gym a high performance gpu-based
physics simulation for robot learning we
saw something similar with a library
called brax these physics simulations
they now run directly on accelerators
such that you can do end-to-end research
on the accelerators you don't have to
switch between devices all the time
which massively speeds up research in
control and reinforcement learning so
this one's called isac gym you can get
it from nvidia which is a bit worrisome
but it looks very cool in these
demonstrations they have an evaluation
and they also do train some policies on
it now that is disturbing but in general
it seems like if you are on gpus and
you're trying to do reinforcement
learning in control settings this might
be a good option for you also in the
domain of physics nimble physics
releases the differentiable human body
model so this apparently is a gold
standard human body model that was used
for simulation and now this library made
it end-to-end differentiable human body
model isn't just one body model but it
is a configurable body model where you
can sort of control the size of all the
different parts and still get accurate
simulations out of it and now with it
being differentiable there's a whole new
range of applications in research that
become possible with this if you're into
biomechanics or differentiable
simulations i think you should check
this out lvis is dataset for large
vocabulary instance segmentation and the
goal here is to do instant segmentations
on categories that are vast so there are
a lot of categories in these instance
segmentation problems and a lot of them
don't appear very often which is what
they're referring to here as long tail
so some of these things you might have
never seen before we've seen a couple of
these data sets this one is especially
challenging because not only do you have
to recognize what it is you have to
segment the instances so here you can
see examples of donut pineapple teacup
wine glass
wrath i don't even know what a wrath is
wrath
an arrangement of flowers leaves or
stems fastened in a ring and used for
decoration or for laying on a grave
wonderful and bird feeder so there are
even competitions and leaderboards to go
along with that if you're into this kind
of stuff check it out next is behavior
by stanford university behavior stands
for benchmark for everyday household
activities in virtual interactive and
ecological environments we had to bend a
lot of stuff to come up with this
acronym but now it's called behavior
this is a data set for doing robotics in
what are supposed to be relatively real
life scenarios in virtual environments
what's interesting is the creation of
this data set the data sets are modeled
after real scenes so people analyze what
they call everyday situations and they
try to recreate them with objects from
wordnet you can let ais run in this
simulated environment but you can even
do it yourself by vr and the data set
includes vr demonstrations of these
things by humans on top of that it's not
a fixed set of environments but the
environments are sort of described by a
little bit of a grammar so therefore
potentially infinite variations of these
environments can be generated here you
see a bunch of examples of this grammar
so for example fish can be burnt or
cooked or frozen the microwave can be
open or closed the apples can be on top
of the plate and so on the ais are
supposed to fulfill tasks in these
situations and i guess the goal here is
to come ever closer to real life robots
that actually help you in everyday life
the problem i have a little bit with
these things is that even though the
simulations are modeled after re-life
they're still very very far from it
being limited to wordnet i guess limits
the amount of stuff you can put into a
scene the scenes are probably still kind
of regular real life happens to be much
more messy so it's a bit of a question
how useful this is for the end goal but
still it looks like an interesting
problem and it's definitely a step into
the direction of robots that interact
with real life in a more realistic and
competent manner
next news wired writes a new chip
cluster will make massive ai models
possible cerebros says that they've
built a cluster that can run a neural
network with 120 trillion connections
for reference that's about a hundred
times more than what's achievable today
so if you want to build a large-scale
neural network today your options are
you can use tpus which are somewhat
large if you use a cluster of them or
you can just stack gpus together and
connect them with some sort of
infiniband both are not really optimal
as the accelerators themselves are
relatively small and they have to
communicate a lot therefore cerebros's
strategy is to build giant chips here
you can see one in comparison to the
largest gpu currently available so these
things are actually huge now the article
details the various engineering problems
that you have when you want to create
such a large chip notably the chip
itself has to be much more error
tolerant as you can't simply switch out
one piece whenever it breaks like you
could switch out a gpu now gpus by no
means are cheap but compared to this
thing a gpu is certainly a bargain now
they didn't stop at building single
chips they built an entire cluster of
those chips now at least as the article
states it they're just waiting for
someone to come around and actually
train a model on it their ceo says so we
know we can but we haven't trained a
model because we're infrastructure
builders and well there is no model yet
if you have an idea of how to use 120
trillion connections maybe give andrew
feldman a call the bigger question is a
little bit of whether scaling individual
chips is the correct approach or if it's
just better to stick with the smaller
accelerators but improve our abilities
to communicate and shard models i guess
only time will tell
the washington post writes a.i gave val
kilmer his voice back but critics worry
the technology could be misused of
course critics always worry the
technology could be misused so the
article details about this startup
called cinatic that used recordings of
val kilmer's voice in order to make an
ai that can synthesize any text in his
voice val kilmer lost his original voice
due to surgery after throat cancer and
this model essentially gives him back
the ability to communicate in audio in
the way that people remember him
speaking now this isn't a prosthetic i
think he still has to type the things he
actually wants to say but with some good
brain interface this could be an actual
technology for people who lost their
voice to be able to speak again in the
future the article also goes into a
little bit of the possible economy that
could result from this namely that as a
voice actor i don't actually have to
voice act for every project i do i could
simply sell my voice for other people to
use as a sort of a licensing deal the
article also voices skepticism with
respect to that and quotes jay britton
who is a voice actor that says when i'm
an actor i get to decide whether i
support the content it would be a
devastating thing to drop on a voice
actor that your voice is out there
saying things that you might not
necessarily support so the criticism is
that someone could buy your voice for a
license fee and then have it say
something that you disagree with and
rather than sounding the alarm bells
about this i think we should simply
adjust to the fact that yes this is a
new possibility we have but it's not a
new thing by any means i mean stock
photographs have existed for about as
long as the internet has existed and if
you're a stock photograph model then
it's absolutely expected that your
picture can be used for something you
disagree with that's just part of the
deal and no one faults these models if
they appear on such a picture so i think
what needs to shift is not people not
using this for various things but simply
our attitude towards what can be done
with voice technology nowadays
so the last article for today forbes
rights can artificial intelligence give
thoughtful gifts an exploration of the
possibilities and limits of ai's
humanity this is a bit of a fluff piece
for a company that uses ai to sort of
recommend our system gifts for people
which is interesting because usually the
media is rather critical of these
recommender systems however in this case
it's sort of framed as the ai really
understands you and knows what the good
gift is in a moment and what a
thoughtful gift is and so on and you
know in my opinion
they're probably not wrong like most
gift suggestions could be made by an ai
much better than you just kind of
sitting there and coming up with
something so the startup is called
gossby for people who are interested
i just want to show you how these things
might look about so this is one of these
little plugins that you can have as a
youtuber that does a little bit of
analysis for you it's not super useful
but i always enjoyed this feature right
here where it gives you ideas for your
next videos and i'm not going to say
that the quality is anywhere near or
close to what gosbi is doing i have not
tested them i just want to show a little
bit that you get the feeling of what
this might be like so here are videos i
could do i've not looked at these yet i
get three per day because i'm cheap and
i'm on the free version of this product
so we're gonna look at them together
devlog tech demo interactive game well i
don't think that's exactly for my
channel how to enable cnbc news alerts i
think it just estimates my channel as
sort of like a tech channel or something
like this maybe this is because i made
how to bypass neural hash dismiss a
revolutionary product for apple users
this is definitely because i made the
videos on neural hash now and that was
it now usually usually i have to say
they're a little bit better they're a
little bit into the direction of what my
channel is actually doing i guess i've
just confused it with the recent videos
about neural hash but safe to say if
you're searching for gifts for people
that you kinda know a system like this
might actually be a good place to go it
will probably suggest you a bit of
generic gifts maybe personalized a
little bit to what you input about the
person you want to give to and that's
all we need okay this was already it for
ml news as you can see
really nothing happened this week if
you're an ml researcher if you're in
industry or even if you're just
interested please make something happen
for next week please i need content it's
very important
yeah alright i'll see you next week bye
[Music]
you